hey what's going on it's built burner
and it's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday November 4th 2019
what's going on how are ya how's it
going oh that's good to know I am gonna
be in Boston this week
I'm doing the the comics come home 25th
annual Boston buff comics come home with
Denis Leary cam neely
the cam neely cancer house and all that
type of stuff great stuff it's gonna be
say night at the Boston Garden it's
gonna be an incredible lineup I think
it's all sold out there might be a few
tickets left
go online talk to a scalper whatever the
hell it is you do another announcement
here when the [ __ ] is it scrolling up
scrolling scrolling scrolling the 8th
annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit is
going to be Monday January 27th 2020 at
7 p.m. at the New York City Santa
Theatre the lineup includes yours truly
Ronny Chang Judy gold Sam RL Andrew
Schultz Sipho sounds rich boss Paul
virzi and Roy Wood jr. still adding
people to this thing special guests and
whatnot it's going to be fantastic
tickets 75 bucks tickets can be
purchased at the theater box office 131
West 55th Street New York New York one
zero zero one nine or you can call the
city center tickets at two one two five
eight one one two one two or directly on
my website at billboard.com I believe
we'll take you to a link it's been such
a great benefit all of these years and
has really helped out the people that
Patrice loved and was taken care of all
right that is the deal okay and lastly
but not leastly well two more
announcements our [ __ ] town
the absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
one of my favorite people in this
business Todd wrecks his uh the [ __ ]
kind of inhale was that Jesus Christ you
ever look in your body just decide
you're gonna inhale I was like Todd req
new special his new special will be
airing on all things comedy YouTube page
on Monday which is today beautiful mess
okay and then okay now this one's lastly
but not leastly we added a Late Show in
Memphis Tennessee on January 6th that's
a Monday pre-sale is Tuesday
the code is Barbie you are are goes on
sale to the public on Friday yeah that's
gonna be fun I why are you there on a
Monday night bill because I'm gonna go
to the Memphis Grizzlies game on Tuesday
and then I'm gonna drive down in New
Orleans and go to the [ __ ] New
Orleans pelicans game on Wednesday and
then I'm done with the NBA I've been to
a home game of everybody in the league
to add to home game of everybody in
Major League Baseball and NFL football
and then all I got is I got three teams
left in the NHL Ottawa Carolina in Vegas
and I should be knocking those out and
I'll be all done and then I can just
move on to MotoGP and [ __ ] Formula
One or whatever the [ __ ] else I have
to figure out how to keep myself out of
trouble here on the road is i wag my
bony pasty sober [ __ ] finger at you
you need to clean up your life all right
with that let's get to let's get to what
the [ __ ] everybody wants to hear me talk
about I already know I bet I got an a
lot of extra listeners for whatever
reason in the Baltimore area let's talk
NFL football but it'll put it up I was
in the air flying back east for this for
all of football Sunday but landed in
time to watch my New England Patriots
play
Baltimore Ravens I gotta tell you as
much as the score seemed a little upside
I thought it was a [ __ ] great game
Baltimore came out and just scored it
will ran right through a defense like it
was [ __ ] butter and then all of a
sudden they're up 17 to nothing right
you know
you think [ __ ] Bill Belichick is
gonna put up with that of course not do
you think the [ __ ] Patriots don't
have pride or in that [ __ ] so then we
[ __ ] adjusted to whatever the [ __ ]
they were doing which is beyond my
comprehension of the game of football
with my little flat screen TV here I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened all of
a sudden we come roaring back was in
1713 or something like that I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was at the half and
then it was like okay here come the
Patriots and this young Baltimore Ravens
team how are they going to handle it
well guess what they [ __ ] handled it
was very impressed
they didn't fold up you know like like a
[ __ ] something like a shirt you're
packing I don't have a reference and
they hung on and then they won quite
quite impressively and I was very
impressed with Lamar Jackson in that we
contained him and he wasn't running all
around the field and he showed that he
could be a [ __ ] pocket passer I was
amazed and how well when you took away
that facet of his game that he was still
able to just stand in the pocket so I
think this kid has a long career ahead
of him because I was worried when I saw
him running around like a [ __ ]
running back which is never a good thing
I don't give a [ __ ] how many games you
win in how many [ __ ] yards he's
getting it is never a good plan of
attack to have your [ __ ] quarterback
running around like a running back
because he's going to get hurt like a
[ __ ] running back and then you're
going to be [ __ ] but what I saw
yesterday if I could judge somebody at
one [ __ ] game which is always a crazy
thing to do I think he's got a long
amazing career ahead of him and not
to Pat myself on the back but didn't I
say I've been saying this all year the
Patriots haven't been playing anybody
we're kicking the [ __ ] out of teams that
suck which is good but our season starts
when we play the [ __ ] Ravens and so
now I but I didn't even watch ESPN so
I'm now I imagine just like I said they
probably on there did your Patriots
which is the business that ESPN is in
they're not that dumb they just have
what is they got four [ __ ] channels
three or four of them they have like 72
hours of sports that they have to
[ __ ] 72 hours they have to fill up
every single [ __ ] day the games don't
come on until night so what do you
there's nothing they can do other than
light their fires on it their heads on
fire I'm sorry like their heads on fire
and scream crazy [ __ ] all day hoping
you're gonna stop and watch it that's
basically the business there they're in
because the internet has [ __ ] them has
come along and taking them out at the
[ __ ] and then their [ __ ] habit -
knees they're so don't listen any of
that [ __ ] alright the Patriots are right
where they are every [ __ ] year
you know before more often than not they
go on to win the Super Bowl so I am NOT
concerned as a Patriots fan there's a
lot of positives from this game as far
as like I love when the Patriots go and
play a team in the playoffs that we
already lost to that's been good for us
every year this [ __ ] happens we come
in the [ __ ] Chiefs kick the [ __ ] out
of us you know maybe this is who knows
you never [ __ ] know but
congratulations to the Baltimore Ravens
played a [ __ ] great game great
defense the whole [ __ ] team just
looked really good and the less angrier
Harbaugh he's had a pretty good record
against us so I figured it was going to
be a tough game only 17 nothing I
thought we were gonna get smoked and
then we came back at that way maybe
we're
in this game I had no like predictions
of the game like whatever was happening
was what I was like which is what's got
to happen now this is happening so
that's what's gonna happen so I don't
know [ __ ] I'm just a [ __ ] comedian
that watches this dumb [ __ ] and gets
[ __ ] you know crazy about it so I
actually sent out a tweet during the
game making fun of one of one of the
[ __ ] Ravens players as far as like he
broke up a past this corner back and I
said he proceeded to [ __ ] celebrate
the way I would have celebrated if I was
stranded on an island and figured out
how to make a boat I'm trying to think
when in my life I could ever do
something that would cause me to stand
up scream to the heavens and thump my
[ __ ] chest I mean it's just a
funniest [ __ ] thing and every time I
do this right all these guys were going
like I write bill this jokes gettin old
you [ __ ] you know the stupid Clint
Eastwood him on the front line you
[ __ ] hacks don't you even look to see
that forty people already sent that you
dumb [ __ ] is I've maintained with the
gift the gift is for [ __ ] for
somebody or Jif whatever the [ __ ] it is
it's for somebody who isn't funny enough
to write a joke they're like joke peds
for all you guys say and then I'm just
this old man I've been doing that joke
it's speaking of comics come home I did
it on comics come home in like 1996 1996
so I was [ __ ] 28 years old so this is
an old man [ __ ] it's been slowly it was
out of control enough by 1996 that I had
already done a bit on it and it killed
forget about now that's just back one
like this touchdown celebrations we're
getting ridiculous like they were
running out of ideas and then that was
becoming more and more I'll tell you
what was a great one as far as like
ridiculous celebrating was the 49ers
this week who looked [ __ ] great by
the way
forty-niners come in and oh it also
speaking well how about Seattle sneaky
pete up they're coming back i missed the
game but [ __ ] beat Aaron Rodgers and
the Green Bay Packers
I believe in Lambeau in overtime you got
to watch out for those guys - there's a
Ledge some teams all of a sudden it's
time to [ __ ] show what they're gonna
be doing boys my head is on fire
look at me I'm saying crazy things
anyway
the 49ers won Thursday Night Football -
still the I think they're the last
undefeated team in the NFL so if the
Patriots don't want it this year I want
the 49ers to win it because I just want
them to shut up the stupid [ __ ] 72
dolphins you know with their dumb
[ __ ] undefeated record what did they
do 14 15 16 17 and oh the pagers went 80
nano until they lost to the Giants but
for some reason it's not a whole season
then that's not beating what the [ __ ]
they did even though they did one more
[ __ ] game you had to win less game
though I'll open it
none of it makes sense it's like okay
great back then when when you know there
was [ __ ] one game on in the market
and there was no [ __ ] pressure beyond
just trying to win the game and they
played this Super Bowl during the
afternoon
great job spells anyway now I'm just
took now I'm totally over correcting the
other way it's still an amazing
accomplishment but I'm just sick of here
and every year that they they pop
champagne that's what it is is that
they're celebrating somebody else's
failure that's what makes them annoying
but continuing on here so the 49ers won
on Thursday and Garoppolo which looks
[ __ ] phenomenal huh he throws a pass
to this dude he catches it the guy runs
like three yards to get the first down
it's like a [ __ ] four yard pass he
catches it I think the whole pole play
was like six
and yards them and that was the first
down that they got that first down then
Garoppolo we take a couple of knees in
the game was over
the dude who caught the ball you can't
tell me this is old bad [ __ ] the guy
gets up he was like and he starts
running like like flipping the [ __ ] he
celebrated more than Joe Montana did
when he threw the ball to John Taylor
because he caught a ball a ball for six
[ __ ] yards for a first [ __ ] down
to help ice a regular-season game
alright this is not old man [ __ ] and
this is also not a this is this is what
[ __ ] annoys me about it is the last
thing now this isn'ta last thing I'm
gonna keep [ __ ] talking about it
because it keeps happening these are not
legit celebrations these are not people
playing with the motions this is all
ego-driven building your brand trying to
get yourself on [ __ ] the SPN or
whatever to try to make even more money
alright just just stop it I mean when
you're doing the 300 yell because you
got a first down in the second quarter
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's it's the dumbest [ __ ] show I
just wish I had the nerve to walk away
from sports not that anybody would give
a [ __ ] but like it's becoming for me
like driving in LA where it's like Bill
at what point are you gonna expect them
to do what they do every [ __ ] day
look at this guy you know he can't get
his [ __ ] you know he goes from the
lane on the right to the lane on the
left he leaves like the back corner of
his car still in my lane because he's
such a self-involved la person because
he's like well I'm in the lane I don't
need to be concerned with anything
behind me basically the rest of my car
and then the dumb LA cut in front of me
can't [ __ ] negotiate that little
[ __ ] taillight that's in
our lane oh and we'll just sit there
rather than going like half a [ __ ] hair
into the bike lane and continuing the
progression of our lane I flip out every
single [ __ ] time I don't I wish I
just knew how to do like the [ __ ]
make those videos and [ __ ]
and just whatever bill just just let it
go I'll let it go I'll let it go it's
it's great you're right you guys play
with passion
nobody celebrated when I was a kid so
that's why I don't want anybody else to
sell there was no celebrations
whatsoever birthday parties everybody
stared at the floor just celebrated when
there was something to celebrate it
would be basically I know I can't stop
it'd be like if a [ __ ] ocean liner
came in and let's just say you need to
tie the thing to the [ __ ] dock and
you need to do you need to tie it down
in ten different places and after the
first one you tied down you still it's
still a problem and you can eat the
other [ __ ] nine the person just who
tied down the first one ignores the
other nine that's [ __ ] thumping his
chest it's [ __ ] stupid it's a
regular-season game jesus [ __ ] christ
do I got a quote kevin mchale again at
one time we were put in a [ __ ]
playoff series we [ __ ] won the first
two games in that building and then some
[ __ ] idiot on the other team started
to all we're coming out they better
watch out we're coming out we're gonna
do that in [ __ ] Game three and then
[ __ ] McHale was just like well you
should be doing that every night this is
the NBA total [ __ ] Pro we play every
night what the [ __ ] that you guys been
doing the only thing I would be
concerned about if I was a Ravens fan
right now is if somebody on the Ravens
then says something [ __ ] stupid
which is the dumbest thing [ __ ] talking
is the dumbest [ __ ] ever all it does is
just amp the other guy up I don't
understand it hey you're losing and you
feel bad here's something to latch onto
all right I've done and another thing
the the the the uniforms on Thursday
night art sorry okay but for all you
guys say that I'm doing this old man
[ __ ] I've been talking about this since
1996 okay
I was 28 years old I had a full a tear
no crow's feet I had my whole life ahead
of me and I was already talking about
how [ __ ] stupid it was so go [ __ ]
yourselves
alright let's talk about some fun [ __ ]
Boston Bruins are on a five-game winning
streak taking it in tonight against the
[ __ ] Pittsburgh Penguins and then we
got them they hate it
Montreal Canadiens I won't think it
maybe you know they might be a little
hungover from celebrating the Montreal
Expos first World Series win via the
Washington Nationals Celtics are looking
good you know after the [ __ ] terrible
game the only game I saw the first game
of the year against the I want to say
the Phillies the [ __ ] Sixers they've
gone on to beat the [ __ ] the Raptors
who else the Knicks and then we had a
comeback win against the Bucks I didn't
see any of those [ __ ] games
I just been sued I've been busy what do
you want from me but I'm paying
attention I'm hanging in there
I'm looking at stuff when I get to
Boston I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna go
down to the the pro shop there that's
for all my nephews and nieces that's
what I'm going to getting all the
goddamn sizes getting them all the
[ __ ] gear you've raised him right
then go out to Foxborough Patriot place
right I'm doing the [ __ ] uncle I'm
doing the uncle run right you get him
all the [ __ ] Sports [ __ ] you know
he's not into sports I don't give a [ __ ]
have him wear it anyways what's he gonna
do the arts yeah I'm aware of Patriots
Jersey this will save them from a
[ __ ] ass-kicking on the bus
alright sorry apologize apologize to all
of you guys who love to celebrate when
you haven't even completed the job yet
I never saw Jerry Rice celebrate like
that ever in his entire career and I
watched him win three Super Bowls I I
didn't see him show more emotion than
that guys showed catching a six yard
pass to end game nine of this season all
right
trick-or-treat everybody I went out
trick-or-treating with my lovely
daughter for the first time you know Nia
always puts together this great
Halloween party every year
she's done it every year this we had our
third annual and it's always kids lola's
age or younger which makes it a really
cool party because everybody's sort of
like in the same age range you don't get
bigger kids they're not bored or ripping
toys out of the younger kids hands and
knocking kids that head you know heads
on the ground and [ __ ] it just becomes
yeah it becomes it's very you know if
you watch those behind the scenes of
prisons it's it's very much the same you
know might makes right if you let
somebody take your toy then you're
looked upon as weak and then it just the
all kinds of stuff happens people
parents intervened Hatfield and McCoys
[ __ ] starts to happen so we keep it you
know so this year was basically three
years and younger it was [ __ ] awesome
times kid had a great time and we were
all joking at them at the party you have
to close with bubbles
once the bubbles come out that's it
that's a wrap okay so what you do is you
have the whole party that's coloring
there's games everything's going good
there's some music they're eating food
and then you give them dessert and then
right as they start to have the sugar
crash and everybody's starting to get a
little grumpy you bust out the bubbles
they go [ __ ] nuts they run off that
last bit of sugar and then they're
[ __ ] tired and then that's a wrap
all right so that's what we're doing but
that's how we usually handle any kid
party we have but on the Halloween one
for the first time ever I got to take my
daughter out to go trick-or-treating we
had a prayer
it's practicing all week you know she
told a little bucket she comes go
Twitter tweet thank you happy Halloween
so she was doing that all week and it
was finally time to go and she was so
friggin excited but then we go up to the
first the first house we just picked one
of those streets where it was just like
you know those perfect sized houses were
there close to each other
flat street I mean and it was a madhouse
it looked like the mall back in the day
during Christmas rush right and so my
daughter was just taking it all in like
wow you know so we walk up to the first
house you know we've got the spiders and
the ghosts and all that stuff and all my
daughter's excitement she just got like
super shy she just kind of walked it up
she's looking at me and I was like okay
go ahead go ahead say it did you just
walked out big barely whispered she's
like good and the person was like hey oh
you look cute and put the candy in a
little bucket and she was so excited she
turn around just smiled me I was like
say thank you she's like thank you then
she walked away and then she got sick
that day I say Twix a tweet she got all
excited by the third house she was like
walking up to the thing she was so
excited for like yeah I can't wait
yelling out her costume I talked
McStuffins she had the best time she was
freaking out like in a good way looking
at all the other kids Halloween costumes
like one of the bigger kids came by
dressed up like a ghost and when she saw
it she flipped out do you at all dad and
all the kids friends laughed no thought
it was really cool that she got that
excited though some other kids dressed
like doing all those dinosaurs you'd
only have those races and like baseball
games when people wear like those big
crazy dinosaur suits and it looks funny
the way like the dinosaur moves as the
person's run and there was a book like
three or four of those daughter lost her
mind at that and everything was good but
then there's always that one [ __ ]
creepy house you know the ones where
they have to try and scare ya and you
got like a [ __ ] three-year-old with
you
just like done please tell me you know
not to do this so we come walking up and
it's just this guy sitting there with a
really creepy looking mask on a younger
kid so um I just got the vibe I'm like
all right something's gonna happen here
so I held my daughter close by right we
got it I was I just came walking up and
run the okay
trick or treat I was just like what's up
buddy like I tried to make it like you
know let's home like please don't do
this please don't give my daughter a
[ __ ] complex here so we get to candy
and then as we go to walk out I feel
myself bump into something I thought it
bumped into like a little kid or like a
dog and I looked down there was nothing
there but like a shrub and then I
realized one of his friends was in there
he they hit you with something that
grabs a tree and I'm like [ __ ] scare
you it's like I'm walking with the
toddler [ __ ] morons but anyway we the
rest of it was all [ __ ] good and you
know her little pail of candy was like
legit filling up and getting heavy so
I'd be like sweetheart you want you want
daddy to carry that you want daddy to
carry it and she'd be like no no dad I
okay I'm not tired
she nope
or at least she was worried that if I
started carrying it that you know I was
gonna think she was tired and was gonna
be over and I gotta tell you something
we walked the better part of a mile like
she walked so much of this neighborhood
and was having such a good time and you
know I take her out for walks and stuff
we know and I kind of know like right
around when she's gonna start like being
like asked to be picked up or whatever
which I never do I always make sure come
on you're almost say almost tough it out
toughen up
right then she walked like twice that
distance and never complained she was so
friggin excited and then I was psyched
in the end I said I said all right buddy
you know it's getting late here you
Europe but all filled up here we're
gonna go to one more house okay she goes
okay
and she was totally cool about it
and then she came home you know was
recapping the whole thing to my you know
my lovely wife you know who was
finishing up with the party there and
all that type of stuff and talking to
her Nana and all that stuff just
recapping the whole thing and the next
morning of course she's asked him for
candy for breakfast I'm like you can't
Afghani for breakfast she can have a you
know after you dinner tonight after you
supper and she was already saying how
she wanted to go again next year but
like my buddies already told me they
were saying listen the first time you
take your kid trick-or-treating
that's top five dad moments I think as
far as like the first 10 years of their
life and I got to tell you it definitely
lived up to the hype so if you're gonna
be a new parent do not miss out on that
because it's you know whenever you take
him out because it was it was [ __ ]
awesome anyway ok plowing through here I
guess I'll go on to the emails now right
is that what I got is that what I got I
think I talked about everything I was
gonna talk about all right let's get on
to the I'm sorry the advertising all
right I always do the advertising first
Sena how it works are emails where's he
at
oh they were sorry policy genius or a
buddy policy genius tis the season to
elect benefits through your workplace
most people know open enrollment as
decision time for health care coverage
but it's also the perfect moment to
release your life insurance needs to
properly provide for their families most
people need ten times the life insurance
coverage then they get through their
jobs which means that your employer life
insurance is leaving you underinsured oh
yeah I think so if you need ten times
that unless your wife and kids are gonna
live it up after you die anyways that's
where policy genius can help policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance for a life insurance plan
that's not tied to your job in minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
to find
your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the red tape I really
believe in doing this without your
spouse knowing you know you don't want
to give a motive money can do strange
things for all you know the person
you're dating is like you know I swear
to god I'd love to push him off a
[ __ ] cliff but you know then where
would I be
he's got diny ten times what his day job
life insurance has given me you know and
then what happens what app you gotta
yogi yeah I'm telling you if you're
annoying [ __ ] like me you really got
to be careful with the life insurance
anyways the life insurance you buy
through policy Jr's genius stays with
you even if you leave your job see
that's a great thing right there plus
you want you everybody to be taken care
of me do you feel like you're taking
care of if I kick the bucket yeah I
don't mean emotional you [ __ ] alright
so when you're looking at your workplace
benefits this month make sure to double
check your life insurance options then
go to policy genius calm to get quotes
and apply in minutes policy genius the
easiest the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance I gotta admit once I got
life insurance and everything like that
I felt great I did it's nice to know if
I kick the bucket you guys will be fine
but yeah you're not gonna come hang oh
okay alright don't you guys miss I miss
what shoot we used to be able to have
time to do this [ __ ] podcast you know
if you had a kid now that's what happens
that's what happens daddy's all alone
doing his podcast stamps.com everybody
you know what I hate more than anything
being bothered with little daily
annoyances good lord that's one of the
truest pieces of advertising I've ever
read you know what I'm talking about
things like being stuck in traffic or
waiting in line or just having to do
things I don't have to do
well guess what I can get rid of some of
those annoyances just by using stamps
calm you know you know about stamps calm
they've been sponsoring this show for
over seven years now and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for the
holidays are coming up quickly get
started with stamps calm today so that
you're ready for the holiday rush
stamps.com brings all the services of
the post office right to my computer I
can buy and print US postage for any
letter any package right from my home or
office
I can even schedule a pickup with the
mail carrier so I never have to deal
with LA traffic at least when I'm going
to the PAS the post office all right we
haven't even gotten to the best part yet
with stamps calm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail stamps calm is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamp start to come click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps comm enter
ber stamps comm never go to the post
office again alright unless you collect
stamps unless you're one of those people
write those people who [ __ ] kill
butterflies and nail them to the cross
of the [ __ ] little felt thing there
whatever the hell they do I think people
collect barter finally they're they're
inherently [ __ ] strange people I mean
you just you just have there's something
that's the beginning that's the
beginning of eventually having
somebody's femur in your goddamn soup
right to make it more flavorful a human
soup isn't that how Jeffrey Dahmer
started first he had a stamps collection
then he moved on to barter flies you
know
then he just said oh no pounced on a
jogger it's [ __ ] nuts right all right
I keep having this reoccurring dream
that a mountain lion every time when I'm
out in my driveway I always worried that
a mountain lion if I my daughter gets
too far away from me a coyote a mountain
lion or anything like that I don't know
what it is it's just every time just
being a [ __ ] parent like the [ __ ]
Stephen King [ __ ] that goes through your
goddamn head and I've pictured like how
like a howl of like in my head worked
out how I would kill a mountain lion but
you know I wouldn't I mean if you're
really honest with yourself you can't
even beat up a house cat like Oh a
[ __ ] cat decides it's gonna start
clawing you up what can you do other
than that that I'm getting clawed up by
a house cat dance I mean that's what you
do for the first [ __ ] three seconds
is your body's dealing with the shock of
what's going on
when that thing is [ __ ] Freddy
Krueger do like five times before the
signal even gets to your goddamn brain
all right that you're being [ __ ]
scratched and by the time you think to
grab this little [ __ ] six pound thing
and throw it at the wall as hard as you
can right leaving it embedded in the
wall I'm just doing this see if it pee
any PETA people get upset you know your
[ __ ] arms you know all clot up so I
figured with like a mountain lion that's
also a cat if you just [ __ ] apply the
same theory to that if that thing's
gonna hit me five times before I even
understand what the [ __ ] going on like
I'm dead so what I've really worked out
is if anything like that happens I have
to sacrifice myself to the mountain lion
and hope that he takes the super-sized
meal
this is [ __ ] morbid [ __ ]
or bill what you could do is get
yourself some sort of firearm or at
least some sort of weapon which is also
right - I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know how to handle anything that goddamn
[ __ ] all I know is I was standing in
line at the at the supermarket and I see
this [ __ ] magazine it says 90% of all
species of fish are gone from the ocean
right classic thing and I'm like oh my
god what are we gonna do about it and
it's like nothing nothing just start
talking about manmade salmon and it's
like that's that's why I all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] people screaming and
yelling like really and nobody's gonna
say anything really it's like well what
are you saying about the fact that 90%
of fishing what is more [ __ ]
important than that
maybe that's why all this celebrating
sports is what's [ __ ] annoy me is
because it's such like a [ __ ]
individual ego me me me me me [ __ ]
thing and listen to all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] talking about gender-neutral
bathrooms and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
when meanwhile 90% of fish are gone all
right that [ __ ] [ __ ] CEO from Exxon
was talking about how long they knew
that spraying all of the in burning all
of these fossil fuels and that that
stays in the atmosphere for 10,000
[ __ ] years what it was going to be
doing what is more [ __ ] important
than all of us being able to survive on
this planet jeez I mean the [ __ ]
we're like I just blows my I think
because that [ __ ] and I Michael IT it's
overwhelming to me - it's so [ __ ]
overwhelming that we're just gonna I
think oh is this how we're gonna go out
just nitpicking at each other about
stupid little social things are you
supposed to say they
we're gonna fish when is Jesus gonna
come back and start pulling them out of
the bucket we're out of fish sir ma'am
ma'am sir whatever the [ __ ] I'm supposed
to say jesus [ __ ] christ the problem
is is everybody thinks like whatever is
happening to them he's the top of the
[ __ ] list of what we should do biggie
this is a time to be humble like I'm
[ __ ] done with sushi I'm never eating
sushi again until I see that [ __ ]
number drop drastically in the other
direction
I'm done with it and I'm alright with
man-made salmon I deserve it
whatever that man made salmon does to me
I [ __ ] deserve it as I am a dunny
that I've never gone to a goddamn rally
got arrested I save the fish [ __ ]
rally I don't know mama it's been a
positive I think we're gonna figure all
of this [ __ ] out I think a lot of us are
gonna have to die and I think that
that's a good thing and we gotta get we
got to adjust the numbers down all right
90% of the fish are gone is because we
are eating all of them because there's
way too many of us all right and we are
the part of the balance of nature so all
right 90% of fish are gone and I got to
watch you [ __ ] screaming and yelling
because you caught a first down pass a
pass for a [ __ ] first down first down
pit and yes I do think it's all
connected all right and I am part of the
[ __ ] problem - I am definitely part
of the [ __ ] problem you know what's
funny is you know how back in the day it
was always like the old man was talking
about all he didn't have and how how
spoiled the kids are today
you know oh you have to walk uphill
don't you guys have a something called
an automobile oh yeah I had to shoe a
horse and get kicked in the head that's
how I got to school right it's gonna now
I think it's gonna go the other way
all the kids after us are gonna have to
pay for our sins of flat-screen TVs in
every single [ __ ] room now we're
gonna have to have our hats in our hands
and they're gonna be like like dad I got
a butter churner today why in my day you
just went down to the supermarket and
bought um much butter you wanted I don't
know it's gonna get [ __ ] weird it's
gonna get weird but you know by all
means let's keep continuing to celebrate
our individual accomplishments do you
know I would be the big that douchiest
[ __ ] comedian ever if I [ __ ] if I
[ __ ] that might have been the bit was
at the pit no the bit was the guy at the
grocery store bagging the grocery stores
and then he starts doing an end zone
dance if I celebrated after every joke
that I told that got a [ __ ] laugh
you'd be like this [ __ ] guy is the
biggest wouldn't it be unwatchable no
he's just having fun he he tells jokes
with emotion all right doing Sunday
football the wrong way all right here we
go here we go here's a guy gonna tell us
how to do it the right way
hey Billy Bragg bout no boos I'm not
bragging I'm not bragging this has been
[ __ ] difficult all right then I'm not
gonna do a [ __ ] dance
on November 27th when I break my no
booze record 368 days I'll tell you the
other [ __ ] night like I hadn't done
stand-up in like four or five days I
literally get depressed if I don't do
stand-up there's something about it it
keeps me [ __ ] in a good mood
all right maybe because I'm walking
around and I'm watching douchebags
celebrating every five [ __ ] seconds
and then I'm seeing there's no fish left
and I'm like why is everybody so excited
okay I know those two things aren't
connected but my world they are and it
[ __ ] it brings me down man so then I
go down and feed my ego I go on stage I
do my little [ __ ] dance up there and
people [ __ ] applaud and all that [ __ ]
I'm gonna start wearing a helmet on
stage and at the end of my said I'm
gonna [ __ ] take it off and just start
screaming at people so I had a couple of
good sets and I got off stage I don't
know what the [ __ ] it was I was like I
want to get I was at the Commerce store
I was like I want to get in my car I
want to drive over to the Rainbow Room I
want to sit on a [ __ ] stool next to
somebody roughly my age that remembers
when rad Dokken and all these [ __ ]
people were toward and I want to get
absolutely [ __ ] shit-faced I don't
know what it was don't know what it was
instead I [ __ ] drove past it and I
went over to I had a bite of cigar
because I smoked if somebody gave me a
[ __ ] Q wide but I paid for it a
air-quote Cuban cigar dude [ __ ] Cuban
cigars all right the [ __ ] that 90% of
them effect this [ __ ] guy gives me
this goddamn cigar right all this nice
guy gives me cigar okay it's not the
[ __ ] guy it's the [ __ ] cigar like
you know I [ __ ] cut it as I'm going
to light it it's wrapped too [ __ ]
tight so now it's like I'm trying to
[ __ ] drink some extra thick milkshake
[ __ ] eyes pop it onto my goddamn head
the final third of the cigar the cigar
falls apart and I was so [ __ ] pissed
the next night I went down and just
bought a Nicaraguan cigar that smoked
great tasted fine didn't fall apart I'm
done with them I'm done with them you
know unless you [ __ ] know somebody
who knows somebody who [ __ ] knows
somebody because the next night I was
hanging with somebody who was like that
and they actually had legit Cubans and
they were [ __ ] delicious
I had a funny conversation with that guy
about he was a cigar guy too and I was
saying is there anything worse than
having a box of nice cigars and somebody
asked for one and you say don't buy you
a cigar guy and they say yeah and you
give it to him and he goes you don't
even have to finish it he knew was that
go I was gonna say and then you [ __ ]
turn you back and the [ __ ] [ __ ]
has put the thing out with half the
cigar left and he slobbered over the
bull of the final third of it like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] anyway emails doing
Sunday football the wrong way hey Billy
brag about no booze I've been listening
to you get upset about DIRECTV the last
few weeks I'm over it I'm actually
excited now that I don't have the NFL
Sunday Ticket I like only having a few
games it's perfect and I think I may
have a solution have you ever heard
about NFL red zone yes I have if not
definitely check it out I've been
watching it on Sunday for the last five
years and I think it's the best way to
watch NFL games basically it flips
between games in lifetime and shows you
the most important plays and drives that
are happening it is awesome if your team
isn't playing because you get to watch
the most important games if a team is
getting blown out they won't show the
game anymore so it's not like you're
wasting time no commercials and it's it
shows all the afternoon games definitely
a great service I don't know if you've
heard of it but definitely worth
checking out I stream it for free online
but some people get it for free in their
TV packages well streaming it for free
sounds like it's illegal so I don't like
[ __ ] people over like you're they're
gonna provide a service I don't have a
problem paying for it that does sound
interesting I don't know I think I'm
just gonna go back to what I used to do
when I was a kid I just watched the
Patriots every week I'm gonna watch
their game every week and then I'll
watch whatever I mean they usually a
local the local game is usually a pretty
good game but what's weird now is I'm in
this [ __ ] L
lay markets so we got two teams which
which always sucked back in the day when
I lived in New York it was the [ __ ]
worst when I first moved there because
the Giants and the Jets weren't good I
moved there in 95 because before
Parcells got there the Giants were in
between you know parcels and and Tom
Coughlin so and it was just the 1
o'clock game was the Jets and the 4
o'clock game was the Giants or
vice-versa every [ __ ] week and other
than the two times a year when the
Patriots would play the Jets it was just
it was the [ __ ] worst
so maybe I'll give that a shot
I'll try and take a look at that but I I
think I think I just like watching one
game what I mean this whole world's just
getting too fast for me I feel like I
got out of Shawshank you know the end
that guy [ __ ] goes to the grocery
store he can't handle it then he [ __ ]
hangs himself Jesus Billy you had to
take it - there you go yeah I did oh
speaking of suicide you know the other
[ __ ] day I had this thing you know
out in Santa Monica which is always the
405 is the [ __ ] out here I don't
want the deal I don't give a [ __ ] if you
live on either just one side or just to
the other side of it if whatever your
meeting is you have to go underneath
that [ __ ] it's gonna take you
all goddamn day so it's already gonna
take me all goddamn day to go from one
side to the other and fortunate I got
the heads up for my neighbors I've stand
in my driveway he goes it's just a
[ __ ] nuthouse down there and I looked
down the end of my street and I just saw
bumper-to-bumper traffic it like [ __ ]
11:00 in the morning I'm like what is
going on well it turns out some [ __ ]
was threatening to kill himself and he
was standing on the [ __ ] overpass
which [ __ ] up a whole highway which I
don't understand why why can't they just
rope off the lane that he's gonna jump
down on - you know I guess maybe because
he could run over to the other side and
jump down on somebody's [ __ ]
windshield or maybe people gonna drive
by and scream and tell him to do it
but this one [ __ ] guy threatening to
jump the what the how much it [ __ ] up
traffic in Los Angeles I swear to God
like if I was a terrorist group it's
like out we don't need to blow ourselves
up here we just go there just stand on a
bridge and threaten to jump we'll do it
on every [ __ ] bridge in LA and we'll
shut the whole [ __ ] city down
we'll just keep doing that Commerce will
be going bad and trucks it would be
phenomenal be [ __ ] phenomenal by the
way I think these uh how these fires are
gonna get put out soon man you got to
give it up to these are the firefighters
that are coming down there I mean the
job that they are doing is it's
unbelievable
it's unbelievable the amount of [ __ ]
people and houses that are in jeopardy
and they're batting average it's like
barely anybody dies you lose some homes
that always sucks but like what they do
is it's just [ __ ] and it's incredible
it's [ __ ] incredible and I'm just
waiting for one of them to get
interviewed who's good-looking enough
and it is good enough shape that LA's
response to it is going to be the
firefighter workout and they're gonna
make you put on those [ __ ] clothes
and start hiking up the mountain
you know except you're not putting out a
fire you're burning calories and get
you're getting that sexy firefighter
look all right reptiles
hey there Bilderberg oh by the way did
you guys see that former Navy SEAL who
said Epstein didn't kill himself I think
he just started something I think he
just [ __ ] and started something it's
really the whole thing is really not
funny if that guy was murdered like all
these experts are saying it's because
there's a bunch of other rich guys out
here that we're doing those horrible
unspeakable [ __ ] thing the two kids
you know
uh justify its just what is it about
money how much money do you need to have
that you're gonna look the other [ __ ]
way to protect that I just don't [ __ ]
get it don't get it alright anyway okay
reptiles hey build a there Bilderberg
you recently had a section on the
podcast about reptiles and their lack of
emotion Komodo dragons probably are not
the best example of this but the most
common pet reptiles are surprisingly
emotional
they just exhibited in different ways
that usually only become clear after a
few months of exposure I had no idea I
was a reptile guy until I got one well
if you weren't a reptile guy why did you
go out and get a [ __ ] lizard they can
be more like traditional pets than we
might first think how [ __ ] leave them
alone bearded dragons are very much like
dogs generally friendly and playful I'm
sorry I have to look up what a bearded
dragon is this a dragon that's too
afraid to come out of the closet out
Jesus bill come on bearded dragon out
dude [ __ ] that thing it's kind of cute
I'm not gonna lie I'll look they put I
had on it yeah you know what I gotta bet
there's something cute about that I'll
give you that okay it still really just
looks like something you should leave in
Arizona or something right sit there and
have that in your [ __ ] house anyway
they're generally friendly and playful
frilled dragons the ones that run on
their hind legs with jazz cheeks
extended oh my god [ __ ] that are very
much like cats more independent but very
expressive and extremely emotional I
don't want some [ __ ]
little dragging running on the back of
its goddamned feet across my house
anyways damn thing is like a hormonal
cat all year round I don't want one of
those the scientific name for a frilled
dragon is the whoa clump clam I the
Saurus kingi I can't be right
the name didn't stick probably because
it sounds like the king of STD ridden
dinosaurs
I guess it's chlamydia something the
vets that specialize in reptile care all
called her vets too so obviously there's
some filthy [ __ ] behind naming this
stuff my chlamydia dis horas whatever
the [ __ ] King G is called flaps see the
pictures I don't have the pictures here
anyways you were right about Komodos
their reptilian is [ __ ] but not all
reptiles are cold and dead-eyed some are
very can be very expressive surprisingly
sweet and some can you lost all the
words head can be downright emotional
what could be downright emo alright love
the special of the podcasts all things
calming Ephesus family thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself alright I don't know
reptiles are just they I don't know I I
you know that person in the bar you just
know I'm not [ __ ] with them that's
what reptiles are they got the same
[ __ ] look in the face look in their
eyes alright bill but where would you go
okay dear Billy downtown you got your
the helicopters license but when Los
Angeles Oh capital whe and when Los
Angeles can't sustain itself anymore and
trucks bringing food into the city
starts slowing down where are you going
to go you've established yourself as a
pretty secretive guy so I wouldn't
expect you to tell us where your safe
haven land is located I'll tell you
right now I have nothing I don't have a
helicopter egg I got nothing
it was a crazy idea and then I just
got into helicopters it was more the
crazy idea made me look at a helicopters
and I just got into him anyways he goes
but it's also sounds like you might not
have that in place my plan you asked
I didn't ask in the next year or two I'm
buying a cheap cabin in Maine near a
lake with fish of fresh water well and
land to gross [ __ ] they go for under
fifty grand yeah and good luck keeping
that you think everybody's just gonna
stay in the city and [ __ ] die while
you sit there in a lake fishing I'll
tell you it's gonna be safe as the
people who just leave society and can
live out in the mountains like goddamn
grizzly [ __ ] Adams those people those
people will be fine hopefully but you
know if we keep doing what we're doing
in just as the temp every place is going
to be affected and all that [ __ ] it's so
and and the fact that they're still
debating it and they're still throwing
money against like the studies of it
it's insane it's [ __ ] insane I don't
want to talk about how [ __ ] [ __ ] it
that's not even doable thing you do i
credit card debt hey Bill I have an
ongoing stupid situation I got into a
cycle of paying the minimum amount on my
credit card I've been there I've been
that we've all done it and after a while
my credit card balance now sits at
around 9 grand
this started before I got married a
couple years ago fast-forward to now
where my wife and I share bank accounts
so she is unaware of this debt here's
the kicker we both have good jobs I own
my own business and make a decent amount
of money there's more than enough money
in our joint account to wipe out that
credit card balance without it making
things tight for us
together we have over six figures and
investments and very little left on our
mortgage I also have my own business
account that does not have access to
that what
I also have my own business account that
she does not have access to that I can
cover the balance of my debt probably
without her noticing my question is do I
come clean and say I have this debt
that's been bothering me and I just
didn't know how to bring it up or do I
cover it from my business account and
move on with my life I feel so dumb
just making these minimum payments each
month when I can easily cover the amount
well considering the fact that you got
the [ __ ] money and you're coming from
a good place you embarrassed and all
that I would just be honest with her I
don't think it's that big a deal if it's
just 9 grand I think you'll be all right
it's when you have you know all of that
debt and you know your wife thought you
were financially ok and then you're
actually the exact opposite ok it's just
you guys are still okay you're just nine
thousand dollars less okay
I would get rid of it it's great you
almost paid off your mortgage just
another huge thing I think you're in the
perfect place that if you were going to
tell her I think you'll be okay alright
overrated
underrated all right overrated big
houses vaulted ceilings storage rooms
for all this [ __ ] you don't use all this
guys singing singing my song here and
having two kitchens are all luxuries
that no one really needs absolutely what
the [ __ ] you need 15 feet ceilings for
you like how wide open it is go the [ __ ]
outside I think think this is going to
start being the prevailing sort of maybe
push back I don't know I don't know what
underrated mail slots connected to your
house mail goes directly into your home
it's perfect the USPS aka the government
is trying to make me put a mailbox in
front of my house so that the mailman
mail lady's mail people don't have to
walk don't have to walk anymore yes
it snows here and I forgot to shovel one
day and didn't and they didn't deliver
my mail for a week now they want me to
pay money for a mailbox and also shovel
the whole goddamn curb and straight in
front of my house snowplows go by so the
piles of snow would end up being 2 to 3
feet high on average oh shut up [ __ ]
[ __ ]
get out there and shovel the goddamn
snow like that that's the type of so I
used to love that [ __ ] you know fighting
the [ __ ] snowplows I liked it
everybody else on the [ __ ] Street
quitting and you didn't it says
something about you remind me of I used
to work with somebody back in the day
when I worked in a warehouse he would
eat like [ __ ] wings and have barbeque
sauce all over his face and in his beer
to be like Jesus Christ dude wipe your
face and he and he goes what's the point
it's just gonna get all messy again and
he would just continue to eat until the
end then he would wipe his face off know
one thing if he was like trying to be a
conservationist environmentalist or
something a list and he was trying to
[ __ ] save napkins that's one thing
but he was just [ __ ] lazy fat [ __ ]
who wanted to keep shoving food in his
mouth
somehow that reminded me of that with
you just [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
snowplow well it's just gonna melt I
mean what's the point
underrated indoor parking I'm a 24 year
old guy in Wisconsin and this year I got
a job after graduating from school and
moved into my own apartment
that has underground parking this is the
first time in life that I've been able
to park my car indoors at parentheses
and my parents house they got the garage
and at school we only had a driveway
this week in Wisconsin we got our first
4 inches of snow for the year and the
temperature got down to 18 degrees
Fahrenheit when I left to go to work on
Wednesday not only did I not have to
brush off my car and warm it up but when
I got in the car it wasn't freezing plus
all summer the car wasn't even wasn't
ever a thousand degrees when I got in it
I didn't realize what I was missing I
was missing
out on until I had it all it's the
[ __ ] best it's the best - and I am a
big believer that garages are for cars
all right garages they're for cars and
therefore drum rooms got to catch myself
here I hate that [ __ ] like where when
people like I don't when they don't take
care of their cars they just leave them
in the elements you know and then you
open their garage door and it's just
piled up with your [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
unreal man it's unreal so I I don't ever
want to do that I don't I am NOT in the
[ __ ] clutter when you get a kid
there's a certain degree of it that
you're gonna have to have but I always
make sure all the toys are picked up at
the end of the day I just I don't know I
got this weird thing with that [ __ ] I
like my garage is super [ __ ] clean I
got the epoxy floor you could [ __ ]
eat off of it I sweep it up I keep it
[ __ ] nice all right got my little
workout station here I got my old truck
here I got my little [ __ ] place where
I play my drums but I don't have a
thousand [ __ ] rakes and and fifty
million I don't know
you know leftover goddamn [ __ ] that you
just never threw out in suitcases and
boxes and all of that crap I'm not
saying I don't have some clutter that
have to get rid of what about I've been
really weeding it out and not bringing
anything else into the house so having
said that for all you people out there
you know who come out to my shows and
everything yeah just it's the fact that
you showed up is more than enough you
don't need to give me anything arena I'm
trying to get rid of [ __ ] my [ __ ]
house and when you give me something
especially when it's something that you
took time to work on to make I have too
much guilt to throw it out and then I
got this [ __ ] thing alright so you
know
I'm good I appreciate the gesture all of
that [ __ ] just you showed up you we're
good we're good there we go all right
there I got that out so anyways that is
the podcast congratulations to the
ravers men they were like I'm starting
to see the NFL whenever Brady's gonna
leave you know this could be an
interesting thing I would love to see a
game now Ravens first the Chiefs to see
the young bucks the new quarterbacks the
next generation is this continues cuz
who's kidding who
oh my go [ __ ] the tires hit you know
who's getting go I'm never gonna stop
watching I'm just teasing you guys about
the celebrating I do think it's [ __ ]
it's like funny it's stupid it's R it is
[ __ ] ridiculous and like I said and
you could make fun of me and everything
but you want to pull that old man card
I've been doing that joke since 1990
well I did it on TV and 96 which means I
had the joke for at least since 95 26 27
years old so go [ __ ] yourself I was in
my 20s as old as the people who are
doing that celebrating so go [ __ ]
yourselves
I will continue to make fun of it and as
much as you guys say the joke is getting
old
I got 12,000 [ __ ] likes all right
maybe you're right I don't give a [ __ ]
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in and get on you on Thursday
go Bruins they got back-to-back they got
depends tonight and then they got to
[ __ ] hate it halfs on on Tuesday all
right that's it I'll talk to you soon